[Music]
hi what a lovely theater
what a lovely envelope but immediately
yes
somewhere out there somebody is waiting
very well
those nominated for the Best Performance
by an actress in a supporting role are
Ronnie Blakely in Nashville Lee grant in
shampoo
Sylvia miles in farewell my lovely
lily tomlin in Nashville
Brenda Vaccaro in Jacqueline Susann
once is not enough
and the winner is in the envelope mr.
gray and the winner is Lee grant in
Shampoo
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you I really must have wanted
otherwise why would I wear an old
wedding dress I think we had a fight 20
years ago but he's changed I know I
haven't but I would like to thank the
artistic community for sustaining me and
my wins and losses and and sitting on
the curb whatever it was I don't think
there's an award for what Warren Beatty
had to do to get shampoo on but I
respect him and love him and robert
towne and my director Hal Ashby who
encourages an actor to fly without a net
because you know that he's there to
catch you thank
[Music]